nine people killed four personnel killed
ten victims total three different
tragedies in America in the span of five
weeks all with one common denominator
guns America has a gun problem there are
90 guns for every 100 people in the
United States the highest rate in the
world and every year they killed 33,000
Americans and injure 80,000 others
Columbine Aurora Sandy Hook and
Charleston the names are instant
reminders of the gun violence that's
devastated this country this type of
mass violence does not happen in other
advanced countries it doesn't happen in
other places with this kind of frequency
so why does it happen so often in
America the Second Amendment to the US
Constitution grants Americans the right
to bear arms so many consider owning a
gun to be a birthright in fact 42% of
Americans have a gun at home but at the
same time nearly half the population
believes laws covering the sale of
firearms should be made more strict
turning that into policy is an uphill
battle because it means taking on one of
the most powerful interest groups in the
country the pro-gun lobby and its most
public face the National Rifle
Association few politicians are willing
to defy them even when 20 first graders
were shot dead at Sandy Hook elementary
school in 2012 Congress voted against
introducing stricter gun laws like a ban
on assault rifles and universal
background checks even though these are
measures that most Americans support in
fact for some politicians the answer to
gun violence is more guns following the
recent shooting in Lafayette Louisiana
former Texas governor and GOP
presidential hopeful Rick Perry said you
seem to be suggesting that a solution to
the problem would be to allow patrons in
the movie theater to bring guns with
them into the movie theater I think that
it makes a lot of sense and after Sandy
Hook danarae said teachers should be
allowed to carry guns in schools 57% of
Americans believe that guns somehow
prevent crime
even though studies prove otherwise one
found that gun owners are four times
more
likely to be shot in an assault with
someone who doesn't have a gun and
recent research found that as gun
ownership increases in each state
so do homicides by guns the Obama
administration believes the first line
of defense should be stricter background
checks some states allow people to buy
guns through private sales at gun shows
or on the internet without a background
check at all even the most powerful man
in the world feels hopeless the one area
where I feel that I've been most
frustrated and most stymied so if people
accept the idea that more guns
essentially means more deaths will we
finally see a change in America's gun
culture